but the thing is that the premise for
talking out of it was
well we think you're going to lose the
money that you invest i was like well um
that was my expectation anyway you have
to have a willingness to fail
you have to have a willingness to be
misunderstood for long periods of time
you don't need 150 iq to do what i do
thank god
want to be happy build a life not just a
[Music]
business
[Music]
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know you've got
something more inside you
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something so today let's live your
best believe
life and learn the seven best lessons
from jeff bezos elon musk and other
billionaires
enjoy
okay let's kick it off with lesson
number one trust your ideas with elon
musk
i had a lot of friends of mine try to
talk me out of starting a rocket company
because they thought it was crazy and
what
friend of mine made me watch a video of
rockets blowing up
[Laughter]
and you know there were just lots of
people thought it was a really crazy
idea and there was some people that had
tried to start rocket companies not
succeeded
and that they tried to talk me out of it
and um but the thing is that
but the premise for talking out of it
was well we think you're going to lose
the money that you invest i was like
well
um that was my expectation anyway so i
don't really mind if i lose
you know i mean that might but i mean
it's not
it's not like i was trying to figure out
the rank ordered best way to invest
money right
on that basis uh you know chose space
right i felt like that's you know i
thought wow
you weren't looking at like money money
market bonds triple a bonds
rocket company you weren't like do real
estate yeah you know
invest in shoemaking anything um and
whoa space is the
highest roi yeah that's that is not what
i there's no
it wasn't famous um i just thought that
it was important that
humanity expand beyond earth and we
weren't doing that so maybe there was
something i could do to
kind of spur spur that on lesson number
two
don't be afraid to fail with jeff bezos
there are a couple of other things
that are essential for innovation and
invention
that are not as fun one of them is you
have to have a willingness to fail
you have to have a willingness to be
misunderstood for long periods of time
if you do something in a new way i don't
care
what it is people are initially
going to misunderstand it relative to
the traditional way
and they will they'll be well-meaning
critics
who you know genuinely want the best
outcome but they're worried about this
new way
and they'll also be of course
self-interested critics
who have a vested interest in the
traditional they have some profit stream
tied to the traditional way
um but but doing things and if you want
to if you never want to be criticized
for goodness sake don't do anything new
so
it's it's it's okay though if you have a
willingness to be misunderstood for long
periods of time
if you have a willingness to fail then
what you can do is you can ramp up your
rate of experimentation
so successful invention successful
invention is inventions that customers
care about
it's actually relatively easy to invent
new things that customers don't care
about
but successful invention
if you want to do a lot of that you
basically have to increase your rate of
experimentation
and that you can think of as a process
how do you go about
organizing your systems
your people
all of your assets your own daily
life and how you spend time how do you
organize
those things to increase your rate of
experimentation
because not all of your experiments are
going to work lesson number three
have discipline with warren buffett you
don't need 150 iq to do what i do
thank god you know well you don't need
140 you know 135 you may need 115 or
something like that and
and but you do need discipline you have
to wait
until you see the fat pitch to swing at
because
investing is a no-call strike game you
know if i were a baseball player
and i only like pitches two inches above
my navel
you know some guy could learn that and
he could pitch me you know three or four
inches below that and i get called out
on strikes because i never find a pitch
i like
you can get call out on strikes in
baseball you have to
you have to swing at pitches that you
you don't even necessarily like
particularly after the count gets to two
strikes
in business you don't have to swing at
anything you can sit there and
the paper says general motors at 68 it
says general electric at 115 or so
general dynamics at 63.
and if you don't like those prices you
don't have to swing you can wait there
day after day after day after day and
there are no called
strikes now when you swing when you
decide to buy something
then you know if you swing and miss it's
a strike but it's a marvelous game to be
in because there are no called strikes
and you can simply wait
for that one time in a month or six
months or a year or two or three years
when you really know what you're doing
where you like the price where you like
the people running the business
and then you swing and you only need a
few swings in your lifetime lesson
number four
take risks with grant cardone what's
your attitude to fear and risk
uh yeah you got it you got you got it
you got it you gotta you gotta take risk
the the the best way to stay out of
harm's way is to be the most dangerous
person in the room
right i like that you know yeah like
yeah do you ever though sometimes think
man i'm taking two bigger risks every
scary
every deal i do yeah every deal i did it
make you feel alive
no i know i'm alive i i just i just um
you know like when you take on an arena
and you're like i'm in a book there's 5
000 people here
okay my my my gig
did had seven times that many people 35
000 people
yeah i mean i sold out an arena as big
as jay-z and beyonce would sell out
the difference is i had him there for
three days they have them there for two
hours
on super bowl weekend our biggest
football you know you guys laugh at our
football but
we love it right so so the biggest
uh sports weekend in the united states
of america super bowl weekend
i held my event on that weekend freaking
insane
hey man how you doing buddy good how are
you you got a book coming out don't you
uh you just came out where can people
get it
get it on amazon easiest spot built to
serve
right there let's go man if you guys
don't know evan follow evan carmichael
he's got a new book out build a serve go
grab it today at amazon
there's a good dude right here how about
number five manifest your idea with
sarah bleakley
i actually really manifested the idea
so you know it's like everyone's always
like how did you take an idea and then
start a business well it's how did you
even come up with the idea you know i
was in search of my idea
and at the time my life was not great i
was selling fax machines door-to-door
i was living with my mom i was like 25
years old
and i remember after a whole entire day
of being kicked out of office complexes
again
all day or sometimes my business card
ripped up in my face
i pulled off the side of the road one
day kathy and i was like i'm in the
wrong movie
like what just happened call the
director call the producer
this is not my life this is not my movie
and i went home that night i wrote down
my strengths or what i thought i was
good at
and the only thing in the good column
really was sales
and i thought okay well i know i'm good
at selling
what is it i like about selling and i
realized i like offering something to
someone that they need or didn't know
that they needed that can improve their
life or help them and
so in that moment i wrote down in my
journal i want to invent a product
that i can sell to millions of people
that will make them feel good
and
um and you know what and two years later
the idea came to me
and and i was ready for it you know
people women had been cutting the feet
out of their paneos for a long time
and i only did it one time but i had
already asked
the universe for my idea and i said when
it comes i will not squander it
and i will take it and run with it habit
number six face your walls with jesse
itzler
i always was dancing to my own drum my
parents gave me a really long leash
which was a great gift
for me growing up they let me do
whatever i wanted to do within reason
yeah and i always you know all of us we
always come against this wall of fear
you know this crazy wall of fear and you
can either go to the wall and turn
around you can go
through the wall yes and i was i always
every time i went
around turned around and went back home
because i was too scared
i had crazy resentment or crazy guilt
that i wasn't able to do it regret not
resentment yeah regret
yeah and every time i went through the
wall and got to the other side
it was so addicting and i was so proud
of myself
so uh let me just give you a quick
example when i was growing up
i grew up in new york city uh on long
island
in the 80s when break dancing and rap
and all this stuff was happening yep
and i was really into break dancing i
don't know i don't look like it
but you know get some cardboard out here
man we need to do something might get
some cardboard okay
and um i decided that like i could make
more money
probably if i went to washington dc you
know because the kids in washington dc
couldn't be as good as the kids in new
york we invented this whole
genre so i got my friend myron who's my
partner my sister just got her driver's
license
and i convinced her to drive us to
washington d.c and the whole drive down
i was having all that self-doubt yeah at
a young age
14 15 years old like what if the kids
are better what if no one shows up what
if we get booed what if you know what if
we go there and
i stink yeah and so i was almost talking
myself out i was building the wall of
doubt
up brick by brick in my own head yeah
and when we got there
we went to a little bank in uh
georgetown and we set up a boom box in a
parking lot
of a bank and we hit play and my friend
started spinning on his head and he
passed it to me and a crowd gathered
around
and ultimately after i did my thing more
people came i took my hat i passed it
around and we made about
200 i paid my sister for the gas money
and then
myron and i split 82 41
each and this guy you know he's counting
up the money and he's counting up the
money and he
gets all the money and then he sprints
over to me and he gives me a bear hug
and he goes jess
we're rich and
what the reason why we were rich is
because on that particular trip
despite all the fear this young little
kid that was so scared
i went around that wall and i realized i
could be rewarded
and i was like i want more of that and
habit number seven the last one before
very special bonus clip
is differentiate smart and wise with
jack ma
you have a lot of smart people but you
say there's a difference between
smart and wise tell us about that yeah
the difference between smart people know
what they want
and why people know what they don't want
so i have a lot of smart people it's
difficult to deal with smart people
very difficult it's easy to deal with
stupid people you know they follow they
go to toilet they go to the restaurant
together
but smart people is all different but
what we need a company
is not is not a farm my company is a zoo
we have all kinds of animals
people talk people never talk people
work hard people never
work i mean these are this is this is
amazing
ecosystem of the company that made the
company very very powerful and colorful
i feel happy that and a leader is not
the proof you are smarter than the
others
a leader's job is to making sure
everybody giving their smart ideas out
you listen to them and sometimes
you make a stupid decision because you
have to balance
you have to believe in the future it's
not smart to people
win it's the wise people
win and for the future so
this is what i believe we need more wise
people
our leaders smart machine will be always
smarter than you
are but machine can never be wiser
smart people using brain wise people
using heart machines don't have heart
machines only have chips
so this is what i think human beings
should always
learn to be wise to say
no to know what you don't want
that's that's my view now i've got a
special bonus clip that i think you're
going to enjoy
but before that it's time for the
question of the day i want to know what
was your single
biggest takeaway from this video and
your plan of action
for the next week when you watch a video
and you just get
motivated the sign says you have a 35
chance of actually following through
that's not good enough believe nation we
got to take action
but when you get motivated and then you
create a specific plan of action for
when and how you're going to do it your
number jumps from 35
to 91 percent chance of following
through and when you commit to somebody
else
like posting down here in the comments
below that number jumps to 95 percent
i want to know your single biggest
takeaway from this video and your plan
of action for the next week
put it down in the comments below so you
can follow through and i can celebrate
you we probably spend less money in
marketing than any
company our size in the world we have a
tiny marketing department
and everyone says why oracle's you know
all about sales and marketing
we are the largest employer of mit and
caltech engineers in the world
we are the largest employer of stanford
and and harvard and
cmu mathematicians in the world we are
overwhelmingly dominated by engineering
at oracle
the idea that we are a sales and
marketing company which people
will sometimes will write about quite
often is
ludicrous on the face of it because all
of our customers who buy oracle already
have it
and if you already have oracle there's
nothing a salesman can tell you about
how great it is to make you buy more
ge already uses it the defense
department always you already use it
all of our customers 98 of our sales or
more
are to existing oracle customers
if we don't have the right product
people don't buy more
we will before the acquisition we spend
three billion dollars a year in software
engineering
the company is all about engineering
it's the only thing that works
[Music]
if you want seven more amazing lessons
from billionaires check out the video
right there next to me i think you'll
enjoy it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there you should just be yourself
right i mean i take pride in the fact
that i didn't give what anybody thought
or said
i was just going to be myself i find if
i don't get enough sleep then i'm i'm
quite grumpy i mean obviously i think
most people that way